SVETOSLAV GANOV: Hey, everyone.
My name is Svet Ganov.
I work on the Android
framework team.
And I'll be talking about
Android printing, how
Android puts pixels on paper.
I'll be giving the talk
with Philip, my colleague.
He's going to join
us a bit later
to talk about some more things.
So you're probably
already asking yourself
why printing matters in mobile.
How is it important?
Everything is in
the cloud, you don't
need to put physical paper,
it's outdated technology.
Well, it turns out
that the main reason
you want to have this
printing to your applications
is because your users want it.
So there are some studies that
show that 95% of the consumers
and 67% of the
corporate users want
to be able to print from mobile
applications, which is a pretty
strong signal that
printing is useful,
even for mobile devices.
Also, some developers have seen
that incorporating printing
into their app, they
get better retention.
They have higher probability
of in-app purchases
and the engagement of
the users is higher.
These are all great
examples, but I also
want to share some of
my personal experiences
in why printing from
mobile is important for me
and how it helped me.
For example, I'm always
late for the airport,
always at the last
minute, always running.
So what I usually do is
I login on my device,
I check-in, I print my boarding
pass, I run to the airport.
Because if my phone dies
when I'm checking in,
I have to go in line again,
and I'm going to miss my plane.
So it's really,
really useful to be
able to print from
mobile for me.
Another use case that's
really important for me was I
was recently
refinancing my house,
and my broker is always sending
me one more thing to sign.
It's very important.
It has to be done now,
and of course, it's
in the worst time when you don't
have a computer next to you.
But we have printers
all over campus,
so I'm able to literally take my
phone out, print to the closest
printer, sign the paperwork,
take a photo, and send it.
So it was very, very useful.
And speaking about
corporate environments,
corporate printers,
more and more companies
have the policy of
bringing your own device.
And so in the
corporate environment,
printing is definitely
much more important
than your personal
everyday life.
So I think printing
to your applications
is definitely adding
more value to the user,
especially in
corporate environments.
So if you remember,
printing on desktop,
it's really, really
frustrating to set it up.
Where in the first
time, you have
to download the right driver
from the right manufacturers,
it should be for
the right model,
and if you want
to do it quickly,
you've got a really
frustrating experience.
We just didn't
want to-- we wanted
to not make the same mistakes,
if you want to say that.
But try something else
instead, in mobile.
And we are working with
the printing industry
to come up with a standard
that will work with printers
from all manufacturers.
So all big manufacturers are
members of the Mopria Alliance.
You can see all
the familiar names
that probably you have
printer at home from one
of these manufacturers.
So they came to
us and they said,
hey, we want to work
with you together
to make printing much easier
for the user, easier to set up,
having a single
piece of software
that can talk to printers from
every different manufacturer.
So the user doesn't
have to worry
about setting up their devices.
We also have
members from Mopria,
so they'll join us
for Q&A at the end,
and you'll have an opportunity
to touch base with them.
So I'll be talking about
the Android Print APIs.
But before diving
into that, I want
to give you a very, very brief
review of the Android print
architecture.
So in mobile, the question
of what printers do you have,
doesn't really make much sense.
The real question
is, how many printers
can you find in my
current context--
in my current environment.
So the way Android printer works
is that you have applications
that want to print, which
is what you guys work on,
that use the print API.
You have print services.
So these are the
drivers, if you want
to think of them as drivers.
So this is what our friends
from Mopria are working on.
And you have the system, which
is the print manager that's
the main centralized brain
that connects all the dots.
And you have the print spooler.
The print spooler is just
a part that shows the UI,
shows notifications, shows
you the current print jobs,
and manages the
current print jobs.
So that's a high-level
architecture for Android.
We don't go into much details.
I'll go straight to the APIs.
The main thing I want
to show is how easy
it is to print from your app.
So how do you print
from an application?
The first thing
you need to do is
to get a hold of
the print manager.
So there's an entry point
for the print framework.
It's very similar to how you get
the package manager, activity
manager-- it's very standard
way of getting an Android
standard service.
Once you get the print
manager, all you have to do
is call the print method.
You pass the print job name
and you pass a print document
adapter.
So the print document adapter
is the important part here.
So that's a piece of
software that generates PDF
based on what user
selected in the UI,
such that it can produce
the printed content.
So before I
actually-- before I go
into the details of how you
write the print document
adapter, I want
to briefly explain
how it was a philosophy
of printing on Android.
So when you print
we-- the application
calls into the system and
says hey, I want to print.
And this is where a
collaborative process
starts between the system
and the application
to generate the content based
on the user constraints.
So what I mean by
that is, for example,
user changes the paper size.
So if the paper
size is different,
maybe your application
wants to do
a layout of two columns
instead of one column
because you have more space.
Basically, we want to propagate
all the constraints, everything
the user has selected,
to the application.
So the application is
in the best position
to layout the content the
right way and render it.
Another thing we changed
was how we separated layout
from rendering.
So layout is
figuring out how many
pages you're going to have,
how the content's going
to be placed on the
pages, and rendering
is actually producing the
pixels from the layout.
The reason we did
this, for example, is
if you have 1,000 page
document, you really
need to layout the whole content
to know how many pages you have
and what is on page seven.
But if the user's
looking at page 6 and 7
in the Print Preview,
you don't want
to render 1,000
pages because all you
care is rendering the two
pages that the user can see.
So this is why we have two
separate concepts of performing
layout and rendering.
So this is how the
layout callback looks
on print document adapter.
So it provides you
the print attributes,
which is what the user
has selected in the UI.
And gives you a callback to
tell us when you're ready.
It's completely asynchronous.
With this API you can do-- you
can take any amount of work,
but the shorter it takes the
better, because this literally
affects the UX.
And so one once you're ready,
you can callback and say,
hey, I'm done, I'm finished.
So here's the information
about the document,
it has this many pages
and it's this type.
You could also say, hey, I
failed because of this reason.
And the reason string
goes into the UI
so the user knows what happened.
And also another callback for on
the-- another callback is over
on cancelled.
So the cancelled is if you
notice the onLayout method
takes a cancellation signal,
and this is a way for the system
to nicely tell you, hey,
please stop what you're doing
because things changed and what
you're doing is irrelevant.
So for example, if the user
selects say page size A4,
and you start doing a layout.
And the user changes in the
meantime the page size again,
we are literally
going to ask you,
hey please stop
what you're doing
because there is a
different page size
and you have to
do the work again.
So the more responsive you are,
the better the user experience
is.
So very similar
to layout, writing
is very similar-- this
is very similar-- work
in a very similar way.
So we're telling you, hey,
please render these pages
and we'll give you a page range.
And we provide
you a destination,
so write these pages in PDF
format to this file descriptor.
Once you're ready, you
again, you get a callback.
And you can use a callback
to tell us, hey, I'm finished
and these are the pages
that I've written.
Or you can say, I failed
because of this reason,
which show this in the UI.
Or you could say,
I was cancelled.
So now at this point you're
probably already saying, wow,
this is super complicated.
I don't want to deal
with all these callbacks.
This is just-- all I want
to do is print a photo.
It should be very
simple, very easy.
I don't need to deal with all
this complicated machinery.
And then you also think, hey, I
don't know anything about PDF.
I'm actually the same,
I know almost nothing.
I want to be able to
generate PDF content.
I don't want to learn a PDF
rendering library in order
to print very simple things.
And we got you covered.
So we have a very
simple class that
allows you to generate PDF
from using standard Android
rendering commands.
So we realize that you
probably already know how
to pull pixels from the screen.
And if you know how to use
the Android rendering APIs,
you can use the same approach
to generate PDF content.
And so the PDF document class
is the helper that does that.
And the way it works is you
create a new PDF document.
You create the
page specification,
and you start the page.
Once you have the page, this
is where the interesting part
is, you can literally get
the canvas of the page
and you can render
anything your like.
So in this case, I'm just
getting a content view,
which is just some view,
and asking the view
to draw itself on the canvas.
And once you finish
the rendering,
you're saying, hey,
finish the page
and write the documents to
this stream, and that's it.
You just generated PDF
representation of whatever
rendering commands you issued.
It's pretty easy.
Another very useful
facility we have
is being able to print bitmaps.
For example, you
have a photo, all
you want to do is put
this photo to this printer
in a few lines of code.
And the way to do this
is using the print helper
from the support
library, which is
dedicated for creating
bitmaps in a backwards
compatible fashion.
And the way it works, you
create the print helper.
You can specify some
optional arguments.
For example, here we're saying,
hey, we want to print in color,
we want to print in
landscape, and we
want to scale the
content in a certain way.
And once you do
these small tweaks,
now you can literally
call the print method,
and pass a URI to the bitmap.
And magic, it just works.
So the print helper
takes care of all
the complicated machinery,
doing all these callbacks,
doing layout, doing writing,
and everything is done for you
for free.
Another very useful class--
another useful facility
for printing is being
able to print HTML.
Because for example, you want
to format text in a certain way,
and you want to print it.
A very easy way to
format text as HTML,
almost everybody knows how to
use HTML, and what you can do
is you can format
your text in HTML.
Load it in a web view,
that's pretty standard,
I'm sure that most of
you know how to do this.
And once you do this, WebView
has a method, which says, hey,
create print document adapter.
And this print document
adapter is the thing
that you pass to
the print framework.
So once again, the
print document adapter
from the WebView,
you can literally
pass it to the print managers
print method, it'll just work.
It will handle the
layout, the rendering,
it will do all the cleanup,
it will do everything for you.
It's very easy.
So before I turn the
microphone to Philip,
I just want to
rehash that you can
see that we have very
flexible APIs, which
are very useful for
very sophisticated apps
where you want to control your
layout and rendering very well.
For example, if you're
an advanced text editor
you probably want to
implement the print document
adapter yourself, because
you have full control of how
the layout is going
to happen, and how
the output is going to be.
But if you're an
app developer that
just wants to put some
pixels on the screen,
you want to print
a photo, you want
to print some formatted text.
Or you want to render
something instead of the screen
to render this to a PDF, you
can use the old helper classes
that I was showing you.
So you can see that there
is an approach for printing
for everyone.
And we kind of believe
that using the role--
the API with the callbacks, it's
only for very sophisticated use
cases.
So with that, I'll
turn it over to Philip.
He is going to be talking
more about UX and how
the platform evolved over time.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
PHILIP P. MOLTMANN:
Thanks, Svet.
So you saw how easy it is.
I want to show you how the
user interacts with the print
framework.
Before KitKat, the only
way you could print
was the app sends out an
intent with some data,
and the print
manufacturers might
provide an app that
receives this intent,
and then renders the
data onto the paper.
The problem with that was
that the print manufacturers
app didn't know anything about
the content, this actual data.
And the result was sometimes
good, but not always.
So [INAUDIBLE] we introduced
and collaborative approach
where the app, the printer,
and the user interact
to create the print.
So in my example here, you
can see the UI of KitKat.
And the printer provided--
its properties, for example,
what kind of paper
size it supports.
In my case, letter and I
guess it might support,
I dunno, legal, too.
The user can then select which
of the options-- of the values
it wants and then
the app renders
the results on to the paper.
With Lollipop, we
added the preview,
which of course, is very
useful to actually see
what you're going to
print, before you actually
put in the physical world.
And also allows you
very easily to select
which pages you don't want to
print, because you might not,
in my case, five pages
might be too much.
I might want to print page 3.
With Marshmallow, there
was no big changes.
We added one more
capability so you
can say which [INAUDIBLE] you
want to save but most of them
make no changes.
In general, there
are no big changes
between KitKat, all the way
to N for app developers.
So if you write
KitKat capable code,
it will work all the way to N.
So for N, we realized that the
actual printing workflows quite
nice now, and it works well.
But what doesn't
work very well now
is the set up process
of your printer.
So in my example, I set
up a simple network,
as everybody has at home,
and put one Canon printer
onto this network as
a common use case.
Can you run the video?
OK, so I have my
browser open here.
And I want to print this page.
So I select print.
And the print dialog pops
up and shows me a preview.
And it says, select printer.
OK, I go ahead and
select a printer.
I can take this PDF, but
my printer doesn't show
So I guess I have to add
it so I press add printer.
It tells me, I might
want to install software
from Canon, which
sounds reasonable
because my printer
is made by Canon.
So I click on this icon.
I go through the Play Store and
I can install the Canon print
service, which is
nice and fast on N,
because of our improvements
in the install path.
Everything's done.
Now go back to the
print framework,
and you can see that
I install my printer.
And you can see
in the background,
it actually found my printer.
It's wonderful.
So let's go back and select
my print in the background.
So now it's like my printer
and my print button's
there, so I go ahead and print.
This warning will only show up
the very first time you print.
So it won't interrupt further.
Print process.
So everything seems to
be fine, so let's check
if printing is running.
So printing is running.
So I don't wait until this
prints out, it takes too long.
This is basically how the user
interacts with the printing,
the very first time.
Can you close the video?
Thank you.
Once the printer is setup
in a certain environment,
you don't have to go through
the whole process again.
You just go-- say print,
and press the Print button.
This is only for the very
first time you setup printing,
or if you go to a friend and
want to print on their printer.
And you might require
additional software.
The idea was to make it very
simple for you to discover
which software you need without
having to go to a Play store
and searching for something
or reading some documentation.
So I hope you are all convinced
to add printing to your app.
Or maybe you already
added printing to your app
and you want to improve it.
Over the years, we've
found certain issues
which come up frequently.
And I want to go
over four of them,
and comment on them-- how do
we suggest to handle them.
First, when you print
you can actually
suggest what kind
of action boots
the printer is going to have.
So in my case, I have
a portrait picture
of my Android statuette here.
And it would be nice if
by default, the paper
would be oriented in portrait
instead of landscape.
So if you don't
state anything it
might turn up to be
by default, landscape.
The user has to go to
Settings and change it.
And that takes
time away from user
to going back into your app.
So I would recommend to address
as many of these default
attribute as possible-- paper
size, column mode, and this
will make your printer
experience as smooth
as possible for the user.
Secondly, I talked about the
layout and on write call.
There's actually a magic return
code from the onLayout call
that you can say, I actually,
I don't know how many
pages the document has.
Which allows you to
return from the onLayout
call basically immediately.
You can do that.
And if you do that, you
get the UI on the left,
instead of a spinning--
a spinning spinner.
And it's not a good
UI, because there's
nothing seems to be
happening for like five
seconds for the user.
If you return the
number of pages,
you can have the UI on the
left side of the paper,
it seems like it's 17 pages.
And the user at least sees
that something is going on.
So we highly suggest to
implement the layout call
appropriately and return it.
But in the case where
you're layout call
will be as slow as
your write call,
it doesn't make sense
to do it-- work twice.
As in this case, we recommend
to return unknown pages.
Third, this is a
clarification of the API.
So let's walk through
your normal print process.
So you issue the print command.
And the print preview opens.
And then for example, the user
resizes the application if
[INAUDIBLE] in the mold
or rotates the screen.
So what happens
in a common case,
is that they go through an
onDestroy onCreate cycle.
And you could even say,
if you wrote the stream,
the application after
the rotation might
look very different than
your original applications.
So let's go destroy onCreate.
So onCreate, you have to
decide, does printing still
make sense in this situation.
In this case you
don't do anything.
If it doesn't make sense,
you don't do anything.
If it does make
sense, you actually
have to restart the printing
process by calling print again.
Last thing I wanted to mention
is more a plea from my side.
If you render PDFs,
please provide valid PDFs.
Provide valid PDFs that
match the attributes
and that match the
media that is sent.
If you don't do this,
it might render fine
on the Print Preview screen,
but it might not render fine
in side of a printer.
And you might end
up with results,
which confuse the user.
We saw many cases where
this didn't work very well.
So it would be nice if
you take care of that.
Thanks for coming to this talk.
I put the old imitate-- or
our webpage on the slides,
and also our partners webpage.
So please look at them,
and I hope it helps you
with your development.
So I would like to invite
Svet back on stage.
And also I'm very happy that
our partners from Xerox, HP,
and Canon, which are all
part of the Mopria Alliance
would come onstage.
And you can ask questions,
the microphone is over there.
[APPLAUSE]
MING GAO: My name is Ming Gao.
I work for Hewlett Packard.
I will focus on mobile printing,
start with some mobile apps,
and then work on KitKat
with Svet enabling that.
Now working with
them through Mopria.
JEREMY REITZ: Hi,
I'm Jeremy Reitz.
I work for Xerox.
I'm Development Manager for
our mobile and cloud print
offerings.
Really excited about
the improvements
coming out in N today, and
working with Google further.
PETER POIRIER: Hi,
I'm Peter Poirier.
I'm the manager for the
mobile app development
from Canon, I work out
of the Seattle area.
And I'm also really happy to
be working with Svet and Zac
and Philip on the Google and
printing improvements for N,
which are looking really great.
SVETOSLAV GANOV: I'm Svet.
I work on the Android
Core Framework team.
I was the initial engineer
working on printing,
and now Philip's
taking care of that.
PHILIP P. MOLTMANN: So
are there any questions?
No questions.
Oh, Yeah.
Over there, one person.
AUDIENCE: Are there going
to be any future plans
within the framework to
streamline that process?
I mean, you showed how you
have to go to the Play Store
and download these
plug-ins and processes.
Is that ever going to be baked
into the Android framework.
So that just happens
transparently
in the background, the user
doesn't have to worry about it?
PHILIP P. MOLTMANN: I'm
not sure it's a good idea
to install software for the
user without the user knowing.
But of course, we
are always working
to improve the user experience.
So if you have suggestions,
write on this basis page.
Or we are happy to improve it.
Because I know, if
you want it to print,
you want to use it
to get into your app
as quickly as possible-- back.
MING GAO: That's actually
a very good question.
So we're actually doing
kind of both ways.
For the EOS Discovery,
it's more like a long tail.
So you have some printer,
which is kind of special,
it can pick it up
with the driver.
But we also, as a Mopria, trying
to preload Mopria plug-in,
on all these major phones.
So we start with WowWee.
I think Amazon has our product.
So whenever you have
a phone, most likely
the Mopria plugin
will be preloaded.
So that's how we avoid an
additional step to install it.
So we do both.
Yeah, good question.
AUDIENCE: OK, thank you.
SVETOSLAV GANOV: Can I
just chime in real quick?
Just to chime in real
quick related to that.
So in N, we actually ship in
a printer discovery component
that is part of a platform
that is updatable separately
if we need to.
And so it's actually
looking in the local network
to find printers for certain
manufactures and suggests
the right software, which is how
if you remember Philip's demo,
it recommended the Canon
print plug-in, the software.
I agree that the user still have
to go through a couple of hoops
to click the Install button.
But it's something we
definitely want to improve more.
AUDIENCE: Hello, my question is
concerned the thermals printer
support in the platform.
The support for
deskjets or big printers
are quite OK, quite
easy to use and so on.
But are you-- do you have
anything in the roadmap
to support the small
printers like stores,
when you are printing a receipt.
It's completely different,
how the framework
should work to do this.
I don't see it.
I use it already but we have
proprietary protocols to print.
I wonder if there's any plan to
incorporate this into framework
so that we can use the same
architecture and platform
to print to these
thermal printers.
MING GAO: Such a
very good question.
Again, it's really
to the vendor,
who provides the thermal
printer to provide the plugin.
And then I think what may be
additional is the paper size.
So it's a special paper
but the architecture
accommodates all that.
That's the beauty of the
Android architecture.
JEREMY REITZ: And I'll
just build on that.
I mean one of the things
in Mopria Alliance
is trying to do is standardize
any printer company, even
receipt printers that
could join the alliance,
implement our same
standards, and they
work with our technology
that we're releasing.
AUDIENCE: But does
Xerox, HP, or Canon,
do you have these
printers for stores?
Because as far as I know,
you don't have it, right?
Any plans?
SVETOSLAV GANOV: So
actually, we will
be really happy to-- we, the
framework team, the Android
team-- we would be really
happy to work with you guys
to come to see what's
missing in the APIs.
I can see these
printer's are different.
You have a roll,
and then you have--
it's completely different.
But probably the enhancement
to the API are no doubt huge,
we need to make.
But we need to-- we're
not domain experts.
We need your help.
Please, get in touch with us.
Help us, help you.
AUDIENCE: OK, perfect.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: My question
is what about support
for before API
19, should we just
use the old cloud print or--
SVETOSLAV GANOV: Well,
I can answer that.
Before API 19, where before--
AUDIENCE: I mean, it's
not the same service,
it's not the same API so--
SVETOSLAV GANOV: Yeah,
before-- the APIs
were introduced in KitKat.
So if you want to add
printing to your app
for backwards compatibility,
unfortunately you
have to fall back
to the old approach.
Just check the API level
device you are running in.
And then fall back to the
throw over the wall approach,
where you just use
the share intent.
Unfortunately,
that's the only way.
We looked into backporting
the print framework,
but it's not feasible
to all devices.
AUDIENCE: OK, thank you.
AUDIENCE: I have a question.
Does this framework
extend to Chrome OS
as well, and other writing
Chrome apps as these drivers?
PHILIP P. MOLTMANN: So
we've worked with them,
and it's not all
completely finalized
what we're going to do.
But we are, of course,
committed to bringing printing
to Chrome OS as
good as possible,
and also bringing
Android on Chrome OS.
It should print, too.
And we've got to make
this work, of course.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
JEREMY REITZ: Just to
build on that a little bit.
So Chrome actually
has print APIs.
They're not the same
as they are in Android.
But they are available, and
they have a similar life cycle.
Where the user
selects File, Print.
You'd get an event.
You can then respond to
that with the printers
that your Chrome app supports.
And you can run discovery and do
whatever you need to do there,
it could be standardized
using the same things
that we're using here.
And then beyond that is
getting capabilities,
accepting the print content,
and then tracking status.
So all those APIs and hooks
are there for Chrome app
that you can build that can
tie into the native file print
path of Chrome.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, but some of
the enterprises, their printers
are not Cloud Ready.
And they want to bring directly
through the driver instead
of going through
Google Cloud Print.
So for those use
cases, it could be
useful to have a Chrome map as
your driver has a Chrome map.
JEREMY REITZ:
Absolutely, in fact
that's kind of what
I was referring to.
The APIs I'm talking about, they
don't leverage the GCP path.
So you can do a
direct print and not
go through Google Cloud
Print infrastructure,
using those APIs
that Chrome provided.
I think they were released
last year sometime.
But they are there, and I guess
if you have questions after I
could talk more about that.
MING GAO: Actually, there's
a name for that API.
I think they just
released last year.
It's called printer
provider API.
You can actually write
a Chrome app interacting
with that for printing.
But there's more coming
I suppose, right.
Svet?
Because we just heard
an announcement.
I think that's probably that's
what you allude to yesterday,
that now that they going to
have a plan to run all Android
apps on Chrome.
I don't know how that works.
But something's coming.
PETER POIRIER: So I don't
know if the plug-in--
if the plug-in concept
was totally clear.
What Philip had shown with a
Canon plug-in being installed.
So each vendor can
write a plug-in.
So it's up to the printer
companies to provide that.
And then with that in place,
you don't need the GCP path.
You can print through
these plug-ins
and it will translate to
what the printer needs.
And there's also
a Mopria plug-in,
which is more universal.
So any printer from any vendor
that supports the Mopria print
architecture, will work
with the same plug-in.
If that makes sense.
AUDIENCE: OK, that makes sense.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: So this is perhaps out
of scope of the current talk,
but are there any plans
for a 3D printing support?
[LAUGHTER]
SVETOSLAV GANOV: Well
in the typical style
of Google answering
this question is,
we'll look into it.
[LAUGHTER]
Yeah, we don't talk
about future plans.
Honestly, sorry.
AUDIENCE: How can we make screen
print without save as image.
PHILIP P. MOLTMANN: So
you want to print out
what you have on the screen
without saving it anywhere?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I would like the
screen, print out the screen,
not save as image.
PHILIP P. MOLTMANN:
Well you can,
of course, you can take a
screenshot and then in photos
select screenshots and print.
Of course, it gets temporarily
stored on your device.
If that is too
security sensitive,
you have not directly.
AUDIENCE: You've done some study
and you said 95% of the people,
they don't want to use this API.
Have you done any study like in
the retail space, or use case,
you know, printing
would be useful?
MING GAO: So maybe before
I answer that question,
I think I would like
to just maybe summarize
what we have discussed today.
I think you are all
the app developers.
I think the talk really is,
one of the things I want
to emphasize is when you
write the app that prints,
most likely the printer that
you have will be supported.
That's the key thing.
Your questions of the mobile
printing and the use case,
I think we still see a
lot of photo printing,
a big part of photo printing.
As Android moves to
work productivity focus,
I think you will
have more documents.
As you go to Enterprise,
there's more enterprise
related information that can be
printed, we see lots of that.
SVETOSLAV GANOV: And
just to chime in,
for printing what is
important-- I mean
it's like any feature
is, what is the value
I'm getting for
adding this feature.
And the other is
what's the price
I need to pay in
terms of how long
it's going to take
me to develop it.
So we tried really hard to make
the entry point like developing
the future easier.
So if you use the helpers
to print bitmap or HTML,
it's pretty easy.
But in case you need
some other helpers,
we'll be happy to provide that
to make the entry point easier.
Because I think with
enterprise becoming
more and more important
for mobile devices,
I think printing
will definitely--
that's my personal feeling
is that it will get more
and more used in the future.
AUDIENCE: Taking your boarding
pass example at the beginning
to the logical conclusion, and
given Android Wear 2.0 being
more independent
of the phone, is
there plans to be able
to do things like print
boarding passes directly
from your watch?
SVETOSLAV GANOV: In
theory there is nothing--
so I don't know whether
the clockwork team is
going to turn the feature on.
Its literally, it's
one feature, it's
configuration when you
flash you're Android device.
I don't see a reason
not to, honestly.
There is nothing
preventing them from doing
that in a sense that
the device has Wi-Fi,
it runs the whole stack.
So that's actually
going magical.
This will be magical, you
just print from your watch.
Yeah, thanks.
PHILIP P. MOLTMANN: Yeah,
so thank you all for coming.
I'm going to be on the status
page for the next two or three
hours.
So if you have questions
just post it there
and we can discuss it there.
Yeah, thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]